our next speaker names all of their pets
after star wars
they had two guinea pigs named uh
stormtrooper and chewbacca
and they have a dog named rogue one
please welcome molly
um
what's beethoven's favorite fruit
i heard somebody knows it
[Music]
[Laughter]
so fun
okay i also promised jared i would get
us back on track so i'm going to try
really hard to keep this to like 14 or
15 minutes and not 20. um so i am molly
huey i'm the team lead for data legal
analytics and business at bloomberg law
we call ourselves data lab i'm repping
our team t-shirt come see me later
our team consists of data scientists
graphic designers and legal analysts and
our job is to create data-driven thought
leadership for the legal market
much of our work is with survey data and
we work with legal analysts throughout
the organization on the front end to
make sure that we're asking the right
questions because
i'm not a lawyer my data scientists
aren't lawyers so we want to get the
questions right but then we work with
them again on the back end to make sure
that they know how to use the data
appropriately
so as you can probably guess most of our
stakeholders and our end users are
non-technical people so a lot of our job
is being that translator like we can do
the data work you all can do the data
work i don't actually need to show you
demos of actual data things what i'm
going to do is show you all the features
and functions that we've made that make
it work for our colleagues
so i broke this down into our three a's
of our data for everyone
accessibility
this is like
boop i just kicked over my water bottle
okay so what i i said before
my value here is to talk about managing
the communications across the teams when
you have
technical and non-technical people of
stakeholders
and i'm building that into how we on our
team use shiny to make that happen
so i want to give all the credit for all
this great stuff i'm going to show you
to
my data science team linda and princess
are here yay girls team and um also
jackie palmer and tom shen who did a lot
of the um initial
building of all the stuff i'm going to
show you so
back to our three days accessibility um
your stakeholders need to be able to
access your data like they have to be
able to get to it play with it
ideally in a user-friendly way so this
is where all the shiny comes in i'm
gonna get back to that in a second
we also need
appropriate training
because it's no good to give people
access to data if they don't know either
how to look for it or what to do with it
once they have it um so to that end my
team does a lot of internal trainings we
do classes on
um everything from basic numeracy like
teaching people legit how to round
appropriately we teach that i know i see
faces out there it's true
the lawyers and the reporters we work
with are very very smart
but some of them have actually told me
they went to law school to not have to
do numbers like when i ask them to open
excel their mind is just blown
so
we we do a lot of trainings we do basic
numeracy we do intro to statistics we do
um data visualization and graphing best
practices like really what chart do you
use you know people come up with things
that add to more than 100 and they're
like it doesn't fit in my pie
wrong chart
so we we do a lot a lot of that um
so then finally availability and
follow-up um
good stories so your data your your
analysts your stakeholders they can get
to your data they can do it they're like
yes i know what i'm doing and then they
come up with something that they don't
know what they're doing
and they try to run with it and you're
like ah that's good oops sorry what did
i do there
i did like four slides in a row
back to this one okay
so
what was i doing i was telling you a
story um
so we did have somebody that was using
some of our data
and he goes i'm gonna do this it's great
and we're like
nope he's like but i got it from your
dashboard
yes you did but no that's not how you
use it so that's kind of be available
for your good follow-up
all right now i can show you all the
things
but i'm gonna
go back just a little bit in the wayback
machine um so by way of background i
started at bloomberg about six and a
half years ago and it was only a couple
of years after
bloomberg acquired bna the bureau of
national affairs which is a well-known
publisher of legal content
publisher like legit books like lots of
big thick
books
um and i started working with the team
that conducted surveys that bna had run
for 40 years when i got there and my
supervisor was like hey here's your file
cabinet of all your survey data i went
and i looked through it
there were paper copies of surveys with
pii from before i was born so this was
this is not good things so
yeah i digress
we used to run the same surveys over and
over and over again and we would use
spss and we would hold on to that data
really tightly and we would do things
like this
paper copy report
it would have
this is our short one it had 45 pages
our long ones had 300 and we would legit
put tables every single table in an
appendix in the back and just say here
you go and hand it off
i don't think this is a really good way
to work with stakeholders about data
like
yeah
they didn't like us and they didn't know
how to come to us and they didn't know
how to ask questions we would just hand
them a report and say bye
so in 2018 we reorged we gave the data
team much more visibility
and we tried to start building those
relationships and saying okay what do
you guys really want we started doing
surveys brand new ones and people were
so excited they're like oh wait i can i
can ask whatever question i want i've
got some things i want to know about the
legal industry
so we're trying to get the leading edge
content right and we're trying to work
with um
non-data folk
enter shiny dashboards here's where we
get to the r and the shiny parts um
so as expected our folks were really
really excited to have
why keep doing that um
to have access to shiny to new platforms
to get all their data and so we built
them and this the picture i was kind of
trying to scroll over
that's our index like this is the index
of our server and we're like yeah we're
gonna build a dashboard we're gonna put
it right here
and this did not work very well for
people because what we did was we built
this dashboard and we did a new one for
every survey and they worked
but
it was
people had a hard time finding it
they're like oh i can't remember the
link to my project can you send me that
link again where's my project or where's
this one and when we started to do some
things year over year for trending
they're like well that's the dashboard
for last year's one where's the
dashboard for this year's one
so that's kind of where my fourth a
comes in is be agile like we had to
change some stuff up we had to keep
continually innovating and really
learning and listening from each other
to figure out the best way
to make this data useful in our
organization
so
what i'm going to do now is run you
through
a bunch of the steps like here's where
we started and all the iterations and
innovations we've done since which i
think are really cool and i'm actually
not going to show you any code
whatsoever because while i can um and i
had i actually took a class with jared
we brought him down to bloomberg a
couple years ago pre-pandemic
um the data sciences on my team are way
way better so if you want to know any of
the code that goes behind any of this
stuff that i'm going to show you go talk
to linden princess they're here
and i'm totally throwing them under the
bus
sorry guys
um
so here's i want to show you what we had
from the very beginning
you can actually see that pretty well
this is what pops up when you click on
your survey project you have
some stuff down the left rail that'll
tell you you know where things are
you've got a drop down menu at the top
where you could
pull down whichever survey question you
want and get a table
one of the things that works really well
on this from our original dashboard is
this download button so
we pull the tables we pull them into
this dashboard it aggregates them you
get your accounts and your percentages
what we have to do at bloomberg
because it's bloomberg is we can't use
the stuff like high charter to make a
nice chart it makes a great chart
but we can't publish it and we publish
forward-facing content and so we have a
program that's built into the bloomberg
terminal so if you're finance people you
know that's bloomberg's flagship product
um there's a program built in
called toaster
i don't really know why they called it
toaster but the story i like to tell
myself is that you put in pre-tabulated
data and like bing like toast out pops
your graphic
nicely brand standard so
we have to use that in published content
so we created this download to csv or
excel and so people can look at the
table and say oh yeah that i want a bar
chart about that and so they click the
little download button and they get
their
tabulated data in excel or csv that's
almost entirely ready for toaster
perfect so then they just hop over the
terminal do that and then they've got
their ready to publish content and this
is
the thing we're really trying to do with
our stakeholders is let them self-serve
the data teach them how to use it teach
them how to do it so that we're not
always doing
every individual thing for them
we also have a tab on here for data
visualizations thanks hi charter
i find that this is a lot more useful in
talking our stakeholders through the
data to see a visual rather than a table
but again you can't publish it so we
have these on here and
after every survey project we have a
meeting and and we walk through the data
with all the stakeholders and the end
users and say here's what we found
here's what's interesting and they go oh
yeah that's really interesting and then
they go and run with it and publish
stuff or we do sometimes
so kind of the next iteration of that
is this multi-survey dashboard
the thing that we found you know with
the giant index i showed you and even
the original survey dashboards that
worked really well
is that it wasn't all in one place
so
we created this multi-survey dashboard
it's like welcome to the survey
dashboard everything is here our
stakeholders can bookmark this one link
and go to this one dashboard and what
you're seeing
on this slide is this is our intro slide
it's like here's how to use this here's
some here's some caveats
nice big red text about when you have to
come talk to data lab
if you click the survey explorer tab the
very next one on your left rail you get
a couple different tabs you get a drop
down at the top for which survey you
want like not even which question which
survey do you want to look at you can
drop down for everything for the last
two maybe three years
and you start with an overview that
tells you here's the fielding dates
here's our number of respondents here's
links to all our project management
processes so you know cheering
confluence all the ticketing stuff is
right there and then you've got tabs for
question lists and survey responses
the other thing we added is this
the third thing on the left rail is the
survey analysis pieces
when when we get out survey data usually
the result is you know a
brilliant executive summary done by our
graphic designer but also these we call
them analysis pieces they're basically
news stories um that have
a graphic nicely brand standard thanks
to toaster and narrative analysis all of
that stuff and we publish them and we
put out
you know couple every week and actually
a little bit of brag on my people
they're the most well-read people in all
of bloomberg law people love reading
about the survey data um but we get new
analysts in all the time or we redo
surveys and and you're like well what
has somebody written about this yet and
so we started this
analysis piece document it pulls in from
our jira ticketing
service and you can go and you can say
add your piece
and
look for what survey it is and all the
pieces that we've written recently have
popped up and you can tag it in here so
if somebody's new and they're like oh i
want to write on this data they can come
in here and just use the little search
bar and say oh somebody already wrote on
you know legal tech metrics or
you know employee well-being let me read
their piece and see if what i want to
say is new or maybe we can link to it
maybe we can make it a series this was
super duper helpful it's still a little
bit manual people have to go in and
click the the teal add button to add
their piece but everything else like the
actual links to the articles and stuff
is is pre-populated which is super cool
okay so now we're gonna get more
innovations next next is our sample size
indicator so
we
we had all the survey dashboards they
were really great
we had filters dynamic you can change
organization you can change size you can
look at
data by title or by gender
and the problem was people were getting
really excited about these drill downs
and trying to report on seven people
it's not good because back to we have to
teach our people about data so what we
did was we built the sample size
indicator in so now you're in you're
looking at your data you got your
question
you got a nice big n equals right here
and it's green it stays green if you can
use this data as you start doing more
drill downs you get under 30 you get a
like an orange like okay this is you
know maybe a little bit more qualitative
you can do it
you get even lower
and it gives you a bright red like
please don't use this
we made it stupid easy for people like
really really easy you cannot mess this
up if you get orange or red you better
come talk to us before you report on
that data if you got green you're good
next innovation
compare surveys so okay we get sample
size indicator we get all our surveys in
one place and then we have people that
come to us and say
hey well i want to look at this years
versus last year's they can either have
two instances of our dashboard up or
they go back and forth and back and
forth
so we
added this little radio button in the
middle that says compare results and if
you're just looking at one survey you
leave it at no and you've got one survey
you click into yes and it brings you up
a second side that you can pull up two
surveys side by side you can change your
filters on both you've got your dynamic
sample sizes on both
and it's just so helpful for looking at
trending data love it
all right now this is our latest
innovation and you all have to promise
to keep mum about it because this is in
beta and we haven't let our analysts
play with it yet
okay crosstabs
so these these are not hard
statistically
but we couldn't do it on our dashboards
before and people would come to us with
all these ad hoc data requests like can
you just show me this by practice area
could you show me this by gender or by
age
and we could do it
but
making it self-serve
saves a lot of time on our team so that
we can go do other more high value
things so i've got a couple of slides
that just show little little snippets of
this so you can see how you can choose
two survey questions like you still drop
down by survey you've got two survey
questions and then this first one gives
you the same color-coded sample size
indicator of like okay if you're looking
at this grouping together can you use it
or not
and then it also allows you to do
questions that are kind of select all
that apply hey which challenges have you
faced this one this one this one and
this one you're doing a crosstab by that
it's not you can't easily compare the
groups
so if they pick questions like this
they're going to get this nice red
warnings like do not make comparisons
until you come talk to us because we can
tell them how they can do that but i
don't want that to quite be self-served
just yet
um
we also have
the ability like if you're just looking
at you know what the data tables come up
with you can get percentages by group so
this is a select all that apply question
so you can see all these groups it will
also show you
measures of sensor trends central
tendency which is just cool i mean a lot
of the reporting we do is really pretty
basic we're not running massive models
we're talking about survey data most of
the time
but people love reading it and we've got
to make it easy so that's what we do um
wrapping it up because i promise i'd get
jared back on time and i'm oh i'm close
i'm close um so four a's not three
make your data accessible train your
people appropriately be available for
follow-up
and be agile in your process
thank you